Speaker 1: We have a fascinating video of
a former attorney general, William Barr.
Basically laughing off this idea of the blanket
declassification of documents by Donald Trump
and saying, I don't buy it. And by the way, that
doesn't mean you stick the documents in a country
club, which is essentially where Donald Trump
won them. This is really interesting. And again,
remember, William Barr is a horrible right winger.
William Barr stands for everything that I am
against. William Barr has continued to say, Well,
I would still vote Trump over a Democrat, but
William Barr is accurately saying this
entire I put the documents in a country
club thing. It doesn't make any sense.
Speaker 4: I frankly am skeptical of this
claim that I declassified everything, you know,
because, frankly, I think it's highly improbable.
And second, if, in fact, he sort of stood
over scores of boxes, not really knowing
what was in them and said, I hereby declassify
everything in here that would be such an abuse
and that shows such recklessness that it's
almost worse than taking the documents.
Speaker 3: To that point, though, there's
there's some questions over the timeline and
there are some who fall in the camp of this was,
you know, looking at the unprecedented nature of a
raid of a former president's home like this, that
perhaps there was more room for the authorities to
obtain these materials without raiding the
president's home while he was not even there.
You think this type of this raid was was
avoidable? Do you think a second subpoena,
for example, could have been issued?
Speaker 4: Well, I think whether the raid
was reasonable under the circumstances, whether
there is, in fact, a case to be made, and whether
or not as a matter of prudential judgment, that
case should be brought, depend on two questions.
The the character of those top secret documents
and secret documents, how sensitive were they?
And and second, how raw is the evidence of deceit
and obstruction? Do they have really good evidence
from people who were involved?
Speaker 3: What do you think
the answer to that is?
Speaker 4: I personally think
for them to have taken things to the current
point, they probably have pretty good evidence,
but that's speculation. And until we see that,
it's hard to say. Now, let me just say, I think
the driver on this from the beginning was was, you
know, loads of classified information sitting in
Mar a Lago. People say this was unprecedented,
but it's also unprecedented for a president
to take all this classified information and put
him in a country club. Okay. And how long is
the government going to try to get that back? You
know, they jawbone for a year. They were deceived
on the voluntary actions taken. They then went
and got a subpoena. They were deceived on that.
They feel and the record, the facts are starting
to show that they were being jerked around. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So, listen, William Barr, much
like John Bolton, is a horrible person,
but he's completely right about this. All of the
people saying, well, this is an unprecedented
action to take against a former president.
What Trump did is unprecedented. And when your
inputs are unprecedented, your outputs and your
consequences and your outcomes are also going to
be unprecedented, logically speaking. But this
entire you can't just throw the documents in a
country club is absolutely spot on and maybe it
will get through to some Fox News viewers. Now,
I don't know whether Trump is going to announce
William Barr. I barely know the guy. I don't know.
I met a lot of lawyers when I was president. Don't
really know who he is. He hasn't gotten there yet,
but we may soon see that. But on this particular
issue, William Barr is absolutely correct. Even
increasingly right wingers are saying
this is very bad for Donald Trump